C'est très gênant pour moi de devoir toucher un sujet, un thème, une doctrine biblique qui est si claire, si simple,
avec si tant de préoccupations et de tact,
de vouloir nous plonger de manière positive et objective dans les textes
et de devoir faire tellement de détours pour briser des mauvaises conceptions
qui ont été tellement mal posées.
Et donc nous allons devoir étudier la doctrine de la création,
non seulement de manière positive, c'est-à-dire en suivant ce que l'Abi nous enseigne,
mais aussi de manière réactive en cherchant à corriger plusieurs mauvaises conceptions à cet égard.
Donc juste pour reprendre les cadres dans lesquels nous sommes,
nous sommes en train d'étudier la confession de foi de 1689, la confession baptiste des fois.
Et la confession baptiste des fois, ce qui est très important à nous rappeler,
c'est une déclaration des fois, c'est-à-dire l'objectif d'une déclaration des fois,
entre autres choses, je vous rappelle, c'est de nous assurer que nous sommes en train
de traiter les Écritures de manière fidèle.
C'est-à-dire, on essaie avec tous nos efforts, avec les meilleurs critères d'interprétation biblique,
des cohérences bibliques, de prendre un thème, comme par exemple,
la doctrine ou la vérité que la Bible nous présente à propos des Écritures,
et on essaie de résumer par quelques paragraphes
ce que la Bible elle-même nous enseigne de manière claire à propos d'un thème, à propos d'un domaine.
En ayant étudié et commencé par la doctrine des Écritures,
on a voulu démontrer
que pour plus que nous puissions arriver à certaines connaissances à propos de la vie,
à propos des dieux,
qu'ils soient vrais, par observation de la réalité,
par exemple, on peut réfléchir, comme les philosophes le font,
« Moi, je pense, je suis un être pensant »
et arriver à certaines conclusions.
« J'existe, car je pense. »
Ok ?
Ou je peux arriver à la conclusion, par exemple,
que c'est possible que l'origine des choses soit personnelle,
car nous notons que d'entre les êtres créés,
il y a la race humaine qui possède la personnalité.
Donc, on se demande d'une origine morale, personnelle.
On peut observer, donc, les choses
et arriver à certaines conclusions
à propos de nous-mêmes, à propos des dieux, à propos de la réalité.
Et pour plus qu'on puisse avoir raison,
dans nos interprétations,
on ne peut jamais arriver à l'assurance parfaite,
ni à la connaissance pleine.
Donc, on a considéré surtout pour ce qui concerne Dieu,
c'est qu'il y a les thèmes centrales des Écritures,
nous révéler des choses à propos des dieux,
que nous avons besoin,
que Dieu se révèle pour qu'on ait la certitude de la connaissance.
Et si Dieu s'est révélé,
il faut qu'on ait une source fiable de cette révélation,
car Dieu peut se révéler à n'importe qui d'entre nous ici
de manière personnelle, subjective,
mais aucune autre personne
ne pourra être sûre
que Dieu s'est révélé à vous.
Et même vous pouvez ne pas arriver
à des bonnes conclusions
ou à la certitude que c'était Dieu lui-même
qui s'est révélé à vous.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Ce sont les crises qu'on appelle épistémologiques,
des connaissances.
Et donc, nous avons besoin,
non seulement que Dieu se révèle
d'une manière concrète et fiable,
mais que Dieu lui-même
puisse mettre son seau pour nous certifier
que nous avons une origine
commune des connaissances fiables
à propos de Dieu.
Donc, la Bible,
elle est non seulement
l'enregistrement de plusieurs révélations
des dieux,
elle est quelque part
la révélation la plus importante des dieux
dans son ensemble,
car nous avons besoin
que l'auteur de toutes les choses
se révèle
et qu'il se révèle
d'une manière unique,
singulière,
pour que ça puisse valoir
d'une fois pour toutes.
Donc, quand on a considéré
la doctrine des Écritures,
l'une des choses les plus importantes
à considérer,
c'est que lorsqu'on a considéré
l'autorité des Écritures,
on a présenté plusieurs indices
qui confirment l'effet
de quelle est la parole des dieux,
des indices externes,
comme par exemple
sa capacité
des transmissions
si fidèles et si fiables
lorsqu'il compare
avec d'autres sources,
on a considéré
la cohérence en termes
des Écritures,
l'accomplissement des prophéties,
on a présenté énormément
d'évidences concrètes,
objectives
qui puissent valoir pour tous,
qui puissent confirmer
l'autorité des Écritures,
des arguments historiques,
des arguments scientifiques,
etc.
Les problèmes,
c'est qu'aucune
de ces évidences,
aucune de ces autorités
qui pourraient confirmer
l'autorité de la Bible
ne peut être au-dessus
de la Bible.
Donc, à la fin des comptes,
l'autorité la plus importante
pour dire que la Bible
est la Bible
est la Bible elle-même.
Car si elle est
la parole de Dieu,
la révélation divine
avec certitude,
il suffit
et il faut
que la Bible dise
à propos de soi-même
« Je suis la parole de Dieu,
inspirée de Dieu, etc. »
Pourquoi je suis en train
de revenir à ce point ?
Car nous allons rentrer
dans un nouveau thème,
la doctrine de la création,
et ce n'est pas
une question exclusive
des croyants,
les scientifiques,
les philosophes,
on a toujours tous posé,
les religions,
la question à propos
de l'origine
de l'univers,
la vie.
Et il y a plusieurs
propositions différentes
qui sont considérées
comme possibles.
OK ?
Et entre ces possibilités,
il y a ce qu'on appelle
la création divine.
Et là,
je ne parle pas encore
des religions
ou du christianisme.
Je parle même
de la possibilité
que l'origine
de toutes les choses
soit donnée
par un être
personnel,
intelligent,
un être divin.
une autre possibilité,
c'est ce
qui certains proposent,
la génération
spontanée
de la matière.
Donc,
quelque chose
s'est passé
à partir
de rien,
peut-être,
ou à partir
de la préexistence
de quelques matières.
Et là,
c'est déjà
une troisième possibilité,
la préexistence
de la matière,
comme si
au moins
quelques éléments
ont toujours existé,
qui ont pu produire,
par exemple,
le Big Bang
ou la génération
spontanée,
hors de rien.
Nous pouvons utiliser
des arguments
logiques
ou scientifiques
pour chercher
à confirmer
ou supporter
quelques de ces thèses.
Par exemple,
la génération
spontanée
de la matière
est la chose
la plus contradictoire
à la logique,
par exemple.
Car si
nous croyons
que quelque chose
puisse apparaître
à partir
de rien,
on est tout de suite
contraire
à la logique
elle-même.
Donc,
philosophiquement,
c'est invalable.
Et la science.
On n'a plus jamais,
on n'a jamais pu observer
aucune chose
qui puisse apparaître
à partir de rien.
OK ?
Et donc là,
nous sommes devant
des possibilités.
Les trois principales
sont celles-là.
Une divine création,
la préexistence
de la matière
ou la génération
spontanée.
OK ?
Et nous pouvons,
selon chacune
de ces possibilités,
chercher
à observer
la réalité,
à faire de la science,
à analyser
la réalité
et voir
si la science,
l'ordre des choses,
la répétition
des phénomènes
qui nous entourent,
va jouer plus
pour corroborer
l'une
ou l'autre
ou va jouer plus
pour invalider
ou disqualifier
l'une
ou l'autre
de ces possibilités.
Nous allons passer
du temps
pour chercher
à constater
comment
la création
divine
comme origine
de toutes les choses
peut-être
même
corroborer,
confirmer
par la science.
Donc ça,
c'est plutôt
une portion
apologétique.
Nous allons
vers l'évidence
externe
de la Bible,
l'évidence
de la science,
de la cosmologie,
de la philosophie
et nous demander
qu'est-ce qui donne
plus de sens
ou qu'est-ce qui explique
avec plus de sens
la réalité
telle qu'elle est,
quels sont les types
d'origine.
OK ?
Mais même
lorsqu'on va considérer
ces choses,
ce sont des arguments
qui puissent jouer
pour invalider
une théorie
ou pour confirmer
ou pour supporter
plutôt que confirmer
une théorie,
je veux qu'on garde
dans nos cœurs
qu'aucun
de ces arguments
n'a la même valeur
qu'est la parole
des dieux.
Aucun de ces arguments
n'a les mêmes poids
qu'est la parole
des dieux.
Voilà pourquoi
le travail fondamental
pour tous les chrétiens,
c'est sur la scriptura.
Quel est
le plus grand problème ?
C'est qu'ibliquement
parlant,
dès le départ
de la conversation,
les croyants
ne devraient
même pas
se permettre
de trouver
dans l'encadrement
biblique
la possibilité
d'établir un dialogue
avec ces autres théories.
Mais malheureusement,
on a été
tellement fragilisés
par la diminution
de l'importance
de l'autorité,
de l'inspiration,
de la nécessité,
de la suffisance
des écritures
et cela a reçu encore
les sauts
de certains théologiens
qui sont sous la pression
d'une théorie
qui a été popularisée,
sont allés
dans la même direction
et ont fait des disciples
fragilisés
dans leur traitement
biblique.
Le plus important
pour moi
en tant que pasteur,
en tant que théologue
et envers vous
en tant que croyant,
c'est d'être sûr
que nous sommes
en train de traiter
la Bible
à la première place,
telle qu'elle
se présente
envers nous,
non seulement car
pour les croyants
c'est ici
qu'ils se trouvent
les enjeux
les plus importants,
mais aussi car
même si on dit
que des croires
ou non par exemple
dans les six jours
littérales
de la création
ne va pas déterminer
forcément
si quelqu'un
est sauvé
ou non,
une personne
ne peut pas croire
à six jours
littérales de la création
et être sauvée,
par contre
de manière indirecte,
ça peut avoir
des implications
envers les traitements
des écritures
comme autorité
souprême,
suffisante
et des implications
théologiques
vis-à-vis
au salut
lui-même.
On sait
que ce n'est pas
la perfection théologique
qui sauve les personnes,
c'est Jésus-Christ.
nous savons qu'il y a
plein de courants
théologiques
qui peuvent diverger
du courant
réformé,
mais qui peuvent
être trouvés
dans les saluts.
Par contre,
nous ne pouvons
jamais diminuer
l'importance
des conséquences,
des mauvaises
conséquences
pour la fragilité
des croyants
dans leur traitement
des écritures.
Et donc,
c'est très important
pour nous
de considérer
comment nous allons
établir ces dialogues.
Donc là,
on considère,
ok,
il y a trois possibilités
pour cette question,
l'origine
de toutes les choses,
quelle est l'origine.
D'un côté,
nous les croyants,
on a la révélation.
Si on a fait
un bon travail
lorsqu'on a traité
la doctrine des écritures,
nous devrons être
tous satisfaits
avec ce que la Bible dit.
et en appliquant
les principes
d'interprétation
biblique,
comment nous apprenons
à interpréter
la Bible ?
Avec les cours
d'homéletique,
avec les cours
d'hérménotique,
des exégèses,
nous apprenons
surtout
que l'hérménotique
biblique,
même si vous ne connaissez
pas la signification
de ces termes,
les principes
d'interprétation
biblique,
pour faire plus simple,
se retrouvent
dès dans la Bible
elle-même.
Par exemple,
est-ce qu'on a traité
Genèse chapitre 1
comme littérale ?
Une question
qu'on se pose,
c'est comment
les auteurs
inspirés de la Bible
traitaient Genèse chapitre 1 ?
Et on va voir
que tous les auteurs
bibliques
qui font récourante
référence
à Genèse chapitre 1
ne l'ont jamais
traité comme symbolique,
toujours comme historique,
toujours comme littérale.
Donc,
si c'est la Bible
qui doit m'apprendre
à interpréter la Bible,
il y a
quelques flexibilités
que je ne pourrais pas avoir,
qui ne peuvent pas être
justifiées
par les principes bibliques.
Et donc,
d'un côté,
il y a
les créationnismes divins
qui sont les créationnismes
chrétiens.
Car lorsqu'on parle
de la création divine
comme une possibilité
d'origine
pour l'univers,
nous pouvons les traiter,
comme je vous ai dit,
par d'autres moyens.
Par exemple,
les designs intelligents
vont chercher par la science
à démontrer
que tout pointe
envers
une origine intelligente.
Et donc,
c'est pour ça
que j'ai dit
que la théorie
de la création divine
n'est pas
un débat
tout simplement
exclusivement religieux.
On peut avoir
un abordage religieux
et plusieurs religions
vont pointer
envers la même chose.
pour nous,
la révélation,
c'est l'autorité
et on devrait
se faire satisfait
avec elle.
D'accord ?
De l'autre côté,
la première question,
et ça,
c'est important
de retenir,
quelle est l'origine
de toutes les choses
ne peut pas être répondue
par la science.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et pourquoi
cela ne peut pas être répondu
par la science ?
Car la science,
la méthode scientifique,
se base sur
l'observation
des faits
et la répétition
des phénomènes.
La création,
c'est quelque chose
qui s'est passé
d'une fois pour toutes
et il n'y a
aucune,
aucun événement
ne s'est jamais
passé
qui puisse suggérer
une proximité
avec la même
ampleur de la création.
On n'est pas
en train de voir
par la collision,
par exemple,
des météores,
la création
des nouvelles,
des nouveaux
systèmes solaires,
etc.
On veut nous suggérer
ça,
mais lorsque la science
fait des observations
répétitives
de ces phénomènes,
ils sont en train
d'observer
que c'est la même
chose que de regarder
deux voitures
en collision.
C'est plutôt
la destruction
au lieu
que la genèse
de quelque chose
de nouveau.
Donc,
il n'y a pas
la répétition
de ces phénomènes
et personne
n'était présent
à l'origine.
Donc,
on n'a pas
des témoins oculaires
qui auraient pu
observer la création
de toutes les choses.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Donc,
ça,
ce n'est pas
disputable.
Ce n'est pas
en discussion.
Ce qui s'est passé
à la genèse,
l'origine
ne peut pas
être présentée
comme science.
Elle ne peut
qu'être présentée
comme théorie.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et donc,
ces trois possibles
origines principales,
génération spontanée,
présistance dans la matière
ou la divine création,
ce sont des théories
par la perspective humaine.
Qu'est-ce que la science
va faire ?
Quels sont les domaines
de la science
lorsqu'elle veut
rentrer dans ces dialogues ?
Elle ne peut pas
répondre avec certitude
quelle est l'origine,
mais elle peut chercher
en observant la réalité
des évidences
qui puissent corroborer
ou disqualifier
plus ou moins
quelques de ces théories,
chacune de ces théories.
OK ?
Mais c'est important
de commencer par là.
Donc,
personne n'y était
à la création,
à l'exception
des dieux.
Et qui sont
les plus privilégiés
d'entre tous ?
Nous,
qui croyons
à la révélation divine.
Car pour plus
que Dieu,
dans sa révélation,
les Écritures,
n'est pas pour but
de nous donner
un récit exhaustif
de la manière
dont il a fait
toutes les choses.
Son objectif,
c'est toujours
de nous révéler
des choses
qui sont surtout
suffisantes
envers les saluts.
Néanmoins,
à chaque fois
que la Bible
nous donne
des informations
historiques,
que la Bible
nous donne
des informations
scientifiques,
elle n'a jamais
huit heures.
c'est impossible
que les mêmes auteurs
des deux livres,
les livres
de la nature
et les livres
de la révélation spéciale,
la Bible,
soient en contradiction.
C'est les mêmes dieux.
Donc,
lorsque la science
a voulu suggérer
qu'il y avait
des contradictions
entre la Bible
et la science,
elle ne nous a pas
présenté
des lois de la science,
elle nous a présenté
des théories
qui nous ont été
présentées
comme des lois,
comme des vérités.
Jamais eu
une loi,
une découverte
scientifique
qui soit vérifiée
et confirmée,
qui soit respectable
tout simplement,
qui puisse aller
contrairement
à l'enseignement
biblique.
Et lorsque
certains théologiens
ont voulu
nous suggérer
quelques interprétations
bibliques
qui sont allées
contre
la vraie science,
c'était faute
des mauvaises
interprétations.
Les dômes
de l'église catholique
contre Galilée,
Galilée,
lorsqu'il a proposé
qu'au lieu
des pensées
qui,
les systèmes
tournaient
autour de la terre,
ils tournaient
autour du soleil,
l'église catholique
s'est opposée
à cette découverte
qui était habituée
à voir l'homme
comme les centres.
Et donc,
il a été brûlé
si je ne me trompe pas,
exécuté.
Et la réalité,
c'est qu'il avait raison.
Et lorsqu'on considère
les écritures,
on a plein d'indices
qui confirment
la même chose.
Comme des pijobs
qui a les livres
les plus anciens
des écritures
qui nous proposent déjà
que la terre
est suspendue
et que les virages
de la terre
vont vers l'abîme
et qui nous donnent
la sensation
d'une planète,
d'un globe
qui est suspendue.
Et donc,
jamais la Bible
ne donne des indices
qui puissent être
contrariés
par l'histoire
confirmée
ou par la science
et jamais l'opposé.
Le problème,
c'est que
depuis la popularisation
de la théorie
de l'évolution,
et la popularisation
dogmatique,
c'est-à-dire
avec des présupposés
uniformitarianistes
et naturalistes,
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ?
C'est comme si
les systèmes créés,
même s'il aurait pu avoir
une création divine,
ce qui reste pour nous,
ce n'est qu'un naturel,
la matière.
et il veut le proposer
à l'univers
dans un système
fermé,
sans la possibilité
d'intervention,
que Dieu,
par exemple,
puisse
suspendre
les règles
qu'il lui-même
a créées
avec les miracles,
avec un déluge,
par exemple,
avec un jugement final.
Et donc,
les présupposés
de la science
fait que même
dans leur cercle,
pour qu'une personne
soit respectable,
pour plus que la création
divine soit une possibilité,
même scientifique,
même avant de parler
des religions,
une espèce de persécution,
perte d'emploi
dans leur cercle,
a une militance
très puissante.
Donc,
il y a plusieurs,
en disent plusieurs livres
qui vont vous montrer ça.
Donc,
Lloyd-Jones,
qui était,
qui avait une carrière
brillante
dans la médecine,
il est arrivé même
à être l'auxiliaire
du médecin
de la Reine d'Angleterre
à un moment donné.
Il était
très proche
des cercles
de la société royale
des scientifiques.
Et à son époque,
déjà,
il y avait
plein
des scientifiques
respectables
qui voyaient
plein de trous
dans la théorie
de Darwin
et que même Darwin
reconnaissait
plein de trous
dans sa théorie.
Et le plus
le temps est passé,
si on se plonge
aujourd'hui
dans les évidences,
les moins d'évidence
on a pour supporter
ces théories.
Et malheureusement,
l'impact
le plus difficile
n'est pas,
on va dire,
d'emploser
par les systèmes
antérieurs,
la théorie
de l'évolution.
Mais le problème,
c'est l'impact
catastrophique
que cela a eu
envers les croyants.
Un pacte
déjà sur
ce qu'on appelle
un abordage
scientifique,
car on prend
comme certains
des choses
qui sont des évidences
très faibles
par rapport
aux évidences
qui pourraient
supporter
les contraires.
L'impact
sur l'autorité
et la suffisance
des Écritures
sur l'interprétation
et l'impact
et la responsabilité
des théologiens
comme je vous ai
déjà dit.
Certains théologiens
plus récemment
ont cherché
à caler
la pression
de la théorie
de l'évolution
avec les traitements
des Écritures
en forçant
les textes bibliques
pour trouver
les moindres espaces
pour faire justifier
par exemple
la terre vieille.
Par ces mouvements
qui ne semblent pas
très importants
dans la surface,
on a sacrifié
la fiabilité
des Écritures,
on a diminué
la haute estime
qu'on avait
vers l'autorité
des Écritures.
C'est comme si
les croyants
vivent divisés
dans leur cœur
aujourd'hui,
dans leur attitude
envers la science
et la Bible.
En craignant
que la prochaine
découverte scientifique
puisse contredire
c'est qu'on croit
clairement
à partir
des Écritures.
Et donc là,
c'était aux expanses
d'une très faible
connaissance scientifique.
Lloyd-Jones,
l'une des choses
qui l'étonne
le plus,
c'est combien vite
un chrétien
est prédisposé
à se laisser
pressionner
par la théorie
de l'évolution
pendant qu'en même temps
plusieurs scientifiques
très respectables
voient plein de trou
et ne peuvent pas
croire à ça.
Donc,
ça manque
non seulement
de respect
envers la Bible
mais manque
de connaissances
scientifiques aussi.
Donc,
nous devons
et nous allons
jouer
exceptionnellement
pour ces thèmes
dans deux fronts.
Le plus important
pour nous,
c'est de considérer
de manière objective
et positive
c'est que la Bible
nous enseigne
mais nous allons
consacrer aussi
quelques leçons
à considérer
les évidences scientifiques
qui vont mettre
en discrédit
la théorie
de l'évolution
mais surtout
des évidences scientifiques
qui confirment
la déclaration
biblique.
Mais je vous rappelle
et c'est par là
que nous allons commencer
que le plus important
pour nous,
la plus grande autorité
est surtout
les traitements
bibliques
qui est ces évidences.
Vous êtes avec moi
et nous allons commencer
par les traitements
bibliques.
Donc,
la première chose
qu'on va faire
c'est de lire
la confession de foi
et voilà pourquoi
c'est important
de nous rappeler
qu'ils nous sommes
devant
une déclaration
confessionnelle.
Leur but,
leur objectif
de rassembler
c'est que la Bible
parle à propos
d'un thème spécifique
avec sa propre clarté.
Lorsqu'on lit
plein et plusieurs passages
des écritures,
c'est ce que la Bible
dit de manière plus claire,
très claire.
et si nous voulons séparer
la Bible
par des thèmes
comme la création
par exemple,
comment nous pouvons
présenter
ce que la Bible
nous enseigne
de manière claire
ou à partir
d'une déclaration
confessionnelle.
Pourquoi c'est important
surtout
quand on considère
que nous sommes
au XVIIe siècle
vers la fin
et qu'ici
nous sommes en train
de confirmer
par cette déclaration
confessionnelle
c'est que l'Église
croit,
devrait croire,
c'est que l'Église
a cru largement
de manière majoritaire
pendant toute l'histoire.
Tant qu'on n'ait pas eu
la popularisation
d'une telle théorie,
c'était clair
pour toutes les générations
de l'Église
la position
qu'on devrait avoir
si on voulait traiter
la Bible
de manière fiable,
fidèle.
Donc lisons,
!
Donc dans cette déclaration
concise,
nous sommes devant
de manière très résumée
la présentation
de ce que la Bible
enseigne
à propos de l'origine
de toutes les choses.
Ici nous identifions
l'auteur de la création
et par là nous voyons
que c'est
les dieux trinitaires
et la plus à Dieu
les pères,
les fils
et les Saint-Esprits.
Ensuite,
ça nous parle aussi
quels étaient
les buts
de cette création,
la manifestation
de sa gloire,
de son éternelle puissance,
de sa sagesse
et de sa bonté.
Et de quelle manière
cela a été créé?
Donc on a
le qui,
le avec,
le but,
et ensuite
on a la considération
de la manière
dont cela a été fait.
Les quoi?
Et là,
la description,
c'est intéressant,
de créer ou de faire
en six jours
les mondes
et tout ce qui se trouve,
choses visibles,
invisibles
et tout était
très bon.
Avec quel état
les choses ont été créées?
C'est très important
de ne jamais
déconnecter
l'auteur,
les buts
de la manière
dont il a fait.
Si Dieu vise
à maximiser
sa gloire
par la création,
quel serait
l'intérêt
de considérer
que Dieu
serait plus glorifié
en faisant
avec des
des airs
et des airs
des créations?
Qu'est-ce qui
ne glorifie plus Dieu?
Selon son espèce,
chacun des animaux
créés
ou une évolution
entre les espèces?
Qu'est-ce qui rend
plus de gloire?
Qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'il y a plus cohérent
avec la considération
de ces dieux
tout-puissants trinitaires
qu'on a étudiés
et c'est que la Bible
révèle à propos de lui?
Quelles seraient
les limites
imposées sur un dieu
si puissant
de faire toutes les choses
en ces jours?
Et surtout,
les buts liés
à son adoration,
comme on en verra,
c'est intéressant
car
pour tout ce qui est
marquage des jours,
la science peut corroborer
en termes
de l'usage
du soleil,
marquage des mois
en termes
de l'usage
de la lune,
marquage de l'année
en termes
de tourner.
Mais lorsque Dieu
va fixer les septièmes jours
comme les jours
d'adoration
et faire qu'il y ait
les semaines
soit marquées
de manière arbitraire
par Dieu,
c'est le but
de Dieu
de nous conduire
à une adoration
fixée sur ces sept jours
littéraux.
Pour l'instant,
nous allons considérer
tout simplement
par les passages bibliques,
par quelques passages bibliques,
cette idée générale
aujourd'hui.
Mon objectif,
c'est tout simplement
de présenter de manière
panoramique
ces éléments,
l'auteur,
les buts
et de manière légèrement
structurée,
les communs.
OK ?
Et donc,
la définition
de ce qui est
la doctrine de la création
pour nous,
pour les croyants.
Donc,
comment définir ?
Je vais vous citer
Louis Bercoff,
les théologiens
systématiques.
Donc,
il dit
« La création
est l'acte
souverain des dieux
par lesquels
il produit
à partir
des riens
tous ces qui existent.
Et c'est là,
dans un but ultime,
la manifestation
de sa propre gloire.
Cet acte créateur
est libre,
immédiat
et absolument
dépendant
de la volonté divine. »
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Verset 1 à 5,
comme on a déjà lu,
nous dit
qu'au commencement,
Dieu créa
les cieux
et la terre.
La terre
était en forme vide
et il y avait
des ténèbres
à la surface
de l'abîme.
Et l'esprit
de Dieu
s'émovait
au-dessus des eaux.
Dieu dit,
on continue,
que la lumière
soit
et la lumière
fut.
Dieu vit
que la lumière
était bonne
et Dieu sépara
la lumière
d'avec les ténèbres.
Intéressant,
déjà,
les premiers jours,
on voit
que même si
le soleil
n'était pas là,
Dieu faisait déjà
une séparation
entre la lumière
et les ténèbres
d'une manière
qui nous échappe
mais qui rend capable
les marquages
des jours
et des soirs.
Dieu appela
la lumière jour
et il appelait
les ténèbres
nuit.
Ainsi,
il y eut
un soir
et il y eut
un matin,
ce fut
les premiers jours.
Ce qui ferme
les cycles
de la description
du premier jour
et de chaque jour,
c'est cette déclaration,
ce fut
les premiers,
les deuxièmes,
etc.
Ce qui fait que tout ce qui a été dit
d'ici vers l'arrière
comprend
et est concerné
par les premiers jours
comme on verra.
Le plus intéressant
à remarquer ici,
c'est qu'au commencement,
Dieu créa
les cieux
et la terre.
Le commencement
est pour nous
et pour l'histoire.
Bien sûr,
ce n'est pas pour Dieu
car le rien
ne peut pas créer
aucune chose
et Dieu
est la nécessité
impérative
d'un être
d'origine
éternelle,
d'un être
de nature
éternelle.
Dieu créa
les cieux
et la terre
et tout ce qui
elle concerne.
En Hébreu 11,
verset 3,
c'est par la foi
que nous reconnaissons
que le monde
a été formé
par la parole
de Dieu
en sorte que
ce qu'on voit
n'a pas été fait
des choses visibles.
Donc là,
c'est la déclaration
des Écritures
qui est dans
le Nouveau Testament
confirme
Genèse comme historique
et qui présente
la reconnaissance
que le monde
a été formé
par la parole
des dieux.
Donc c'est important
pour mettre
en évidence
et c'est là
où je suis
troublé vraiment
je reste
abasourdi
par la tentation
d'aller dans la direction
de la théorie
de l'évolution
tellement contraire
aux Écritures
mais la réalité ici
c'est un dieu
qui a tout créé
à partir de sa parole.
Quelle serait
la difficulté pour dieu
de les faire
en six jours
par exemple ?
Donc toutes les choses
à partir de rien
à partir de sa parole.
Donc quel est
les qui
si on peut dire
comme ça
de cette création
qui a créé
qui est l'origine
de toutes les choses
et la réponse
de la confession
au commencement
il a plu
à Dieu
Père
Fils
et Saint-Esprit
donc c'est
glorieux
nous sommes
devant
la maximisation
de la révélation
des dieux
donc la Bible
elle nous dit
par plusieurs passages
que la gloire
des dieux
est révélée
dans les choses créées
et c'est les dieux
trinitaires
qui est en train
de créer
toutes les choses
nous allons voir
comment ça va
arriver
à son sommet
lorsqu'on considère
la création
de l'homme
à son image
homme et femme
à l'image des dieux
car nous allons voir
et percevoir
même les intérations
de la sainte
communauté
intra-trinitaire
dans la
complémentarité
que nous allons retrouver
en général
dans toute la création
mais aussi
dans la création
de l'être humain
donc l'un des indices
qu'on verra plus tard
de la nécessité
que la création
des dieux
ait été faite
dans une courte
de duration
c'est
les niveaux
des connexions
entre tous les systèmes
dont on a besoin
pour que la vie existe
nous sommes
dans des écosystèmes
des biosystèmes
tellement
interdépendants
rien que dans
notre être personnel
mais aussi
quand on considère
les relations
de tout
l'univers
toute l'atmosphère
toutes les lois
qui
aucun
designer
de
n'importe quelle
machine intelligente
ne peut jamais
projeter quelque chose
en séparant
les systèmes
dont ils dépendent
pour son interaction
pour qu'ils puissent
se rouler
et donc si
on avait des choses
qui dépendaient
d'une évolution
pour se connecter
futurement
on n'allait jamais
avoir la connexion
dont on a besoin
et voilà pourquoi
Dieu a fait
toutes ces choses
de manière parfaite
dans une courte période
car son objectif
c'était de lancer
la machine
avec tous ses composants
en même temps
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
cette intégration
qui est
supportée
et fondée
sur ces dieux
trinitaires
qui a créé
toutes les choses
unies
même si
toutes les choses
créées
possèdent
beaucoup de variétés
que toutes les choses
possèdent beaucoup
de différences
elles sont toutes unies
donc la nature
elle donne
des évidences
d'avoir été créée
par un dieu
qui est unique
et pluriel
capable de justifier
que les molécules
ou les éléments
moléculaires
qui forment
les petits briques
de toute la réalité
soit un
quelque part
mais qu'en même temps
ait la capacité
de décodifier
des codes
génétiques
qui portent
leur différence
donc c'est tout
simplement glorieux
mais la réalité
c'est que tout pointe
envers
tout confirme
quelque part
les faits
qui Dieu
les dieux trinitaires
et l'auteur
et les trois personnes
de la trinité
ont participé
genèse 1.1
au commencement
Dieu créa
les cieux
la terre
donc c'est une référence
à Dieu père
psaume 102.25
tu as anciennement
posé les fondements
de la terre
et les cieux
sont l'ouvrage
des téments
donc à Dieu
les pères
attribuaient la création
on a plein de passages
à Dieu les fils
Jean chapitre 1
verset 3
toutes choses
ont été faites
par elles
et rien
de ce qui a été fait
n'a été fait
sans elles
et donc
Dieu
a créé
toutes les choses
par sa parole
puissante
et qui nous est présenté
comme la parole
des dieux
les fils
voilà pourquoi
Colossiens chapitre 1
verset 16
car en lui
les fils
ont été créés
toutes choses
qui sont dans les cieux
et sur la terre
les visibles
et invisibles
qu'il s'agisse
des trains
des nominations
des souverainetés
des autorités
tout a été créé
par lui
et pour lui
donc les pères
qui va créer
toutes les choses
les pères
qui va donner
quelque part
l'ordre
qui va professer
l'ordre de la création
qui va planifier
toutes les choses
qui va décréter
et toutes les choses
qui viendront
en existence
en subsistant
dans les fils
ok
la parole puissante
qui soutient
toutes les choses
et donc la réalité
et ça c'est
super important
contrairement
à la vision
naturaliste
matérialiste
qui suggère
que si jamais
même la position
théiste
si jamais
il y a eu
une origine
c'était comme
un horlogier
il a donné
corps d'un horloge
et il a
abandonné
sa création
c'est les rêves
quelque part
de ces scientifiques
qui veulent
s'enfuir
de la réalité
des dieux
mais la Bible
nous présente
comme
une création
séparée
des dieux
toutefois
subsistant
en dieux
en constante
dépendance
et un dieu
qui a libre
pour intervenir
et donc là
c'est important
de rappeler
en Christ
tout a été créé
et tout subsiste
en lui
et donc
la parole
qui a les fils
mais aussi
par l'exécution
du Saint-Esprit
donc Dieu
le Saint-Esprit
nous est présenté
en Genèse
l'Esprit
de Dieu
c'est mauvais
au-dessus
des eaux
donc intéressant
on a fait un parallèle
avec la
la conception
de Marie
quelque part
lorsque le Saint-Esprit
vient l'environnement
l'envelopper
ici le langage
c'est de prendre
cette
cette terre
et celle
qui était
disforme
et vide
et de commencer
à faire
comme une poule
faite pour
porter
les développements
de son bébé
là
dans l'œuf
donc c'est de voir
cette
cette masse
en forme
disforme
et le Saint-Esprit
va l'environner
pour porter
l'ordre
et porter l'ordre
selon les coordonnées
des dieux
par la suite
des six jours
de création
le Saint-Esprit
il est là
en environnement
prêt à exécuter
ce que les Pères
déclarent par les Fils
et le Saint-Esprit
va porter l'ordre
les cosmos
à partir
du chaos
donc là
le Saint-Esprit
s'est mauvais
au-dessus des eaux
Job 33
verset 4
l'Esprit de Dieu
m'a fait
les souffles
de Tout-Puissant
m'a animé
confirmant
de manière historique
Genèse 1
psaume 104
tu envoies
ton esprit
ils sont créés
et tu rénoveles
la face de la terre
un constant
ouvrage
et donc c'est important
de remarquer
les trois personnes
de la Trinité
sont là
en train d'agir
en créant
un univers
distinct
des dieux
et en même temps
dépendant
et subsistant
en dieux
et donc
c'est
Dieu
la Sainte Trinité
qui a créé
toutes les choses
la prochaine chose
qu'on va considérer
la confession
met en évidence
c'est
avec quel but
Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
donc
au commencement
il a plu
à Dieu
les Pères
les Fils
et le Saint-Esprit
pour la manifestation
de sa gloire
et de son éternelle puissance
de sa sagesse
et de sa bonté
de créer
ou de faire
en six jours
les mondes
et tout ce qui se trouve
chose visible
et invisible
et tout était très bon
donc
quelles sont les portions
de ces passages
de la confession
qui nous pointent
directement
envers les récits
des Jeunesses
donc
déjà
il n'a plus Dieu
c'est important
à remarquer
car
la Bible
ne nous présente jamais
les pourquoi
de la création
par exemple
est-ce que Dieu
était solitaire
non
la Bible
elle est claire
pour nous dire
que Dieu
était déjà
infiniment satisfait
c'est les dieux
bienheureux
qui ne dépendent
d'aucune chose
en dehors de soi-même
pour être plus
dans la joie
la communion
interne
de la sainte trinité
fait que Dieu
soit la source
suprême
du bonheur
et de la joie
car
ils sont
autosuffisants
pour vivre
dans un bonheur
suprême
la création
nous est décrite
plutôt
comme un débordement
des joies
de la part de Dieu
c'était pour vouloir
être généreux
envers une portion
de la création
qui serait capable
de réjouir
de la gloire
de contempler
les vertus
de Dieu
de l'adorer
et d'être en commun
avec lui
qui est Dieu
en débordant
des joies
et des générosités
a créé
toutes les choses
Dieu a créé
pour sa gloire
quelque part
par l'ouvrage
qu'il opère
qu'il fait
il ne peut
qu'augmenter
quelque part
sa joie
dans un certain sens
car tout ce
que Dieu fait
est bon
et donc la Bible
en Genèse
vient de dire
à chaque fois
que Dieu crée
quelque chose
qu'il finit
la création d'un jour
et tout était bon
sauf que lorsqu'il crée
l'être humain
à son image
à sa ressemblance
tout était
très bon
et qu'est-ce que Dieu
va faire à partir de là
une fois que son
ouvrage est complète
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
il va se reposer
les septième jour
il va élever ses jours
pourquoi
pour contempler
la création
qu'il a fait
c'est-à-dire
pour prendre plaisir
dans la création
qu'il a fait
donc l'objectif
des dieux
n'est pas
des fers de nous
il n'est pas
un esclave
un serviteur
de notre joie
tout ce qu'il a fait
est pour notre bien
et pour notre joie
suprême
comme conséquence
qu'il a fait
toutes les choses
pour sa propre gloire
ça ne fait pas
des dieux
un dieu capricieux
dans aucun cas
ça fait que ça soit
toujours inévitable
de la part des dieux
que tout ce qu'il fasse
soit infiniment glorieux
c'est impossible
que Dieu
ait un parfait
suprême
riche en sagesse
en puissance
en beauté
mais aussi
en bonté
le fait
que Dieu soit bon
il va créer
toutes les choses
bonnes
et qui portent
bénéfice
à toute sa création
et lorsqu'il est
humain créé
il est le plus
bénéficié
car il reçoit
la possibilité
de contempler
la gloire des dieux
dans la création
en puissant aussi
contempler les dieux
lui-même
de la création
et réjouir
d'une communion
pour adorer
ces dieux
donc aucune chose
qui Dieu a créé
n'aurait jamais
la capacité
de satisfaire
nos âmes
pour mieux
qu'elles soient
comme Dieu lui-même
a la capacité
de satisfaire
et donc toutes les choses
glorieuses
que Dieu crée
c'est pour augmenter
notre contemplation
des vertus des dieux
et adorer Dieu
au lieu de la création
et c'est clair
qu'ici
quelqu'un d'entre nous
cherche des éloges
cherche à être adoré
qui on vit
pour notre gloire
ça c'est injuste
et arbitraire
car c'est déjà
injuste
car personne
n'est digne
d'être loué
surtout dans son état
de corruption
mais dans les cas
des dieux
d'exiger
qu'on vive
pour sa gloire
c'est synonyme
de vivre
pour notre bien suprême
le fait que Dieu
soit en train
de pointer toujours
envers lui-même
pour nous dire
vivez pour ma gloire
c'est la même chose
de nous dire
vivez pour votre
suprême joie
car votre suprême joie
ne se trouve qu'est
dans la contemplation
de ma gloire
et donc c'est la générosité
des dieux
qui a fait
qu'il a créé
des êtres
d'être
capables
de digérer
les vertus
et les gloires divines
de nous donner
les privilèges
de contempler
ce qui fait la joie
de la sainte trinité
pendant toute l'éternité
donc pourquoi
Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
la Bible ne nous donne pas
des raisons
mais avec
quel but
oui
c'est pour sa gloire
Esaïe 43
tous ceux qui portent
mon nom
qui j'ai créé
pour ma gloire
que j'ai formé
et fait
Colossiens 1
car en lui
les fils ont été créés
toutes choses
qui sont dans les cieux
et sur la terre
visibles et invisibles
qu'il s'agisse
des trônes
des dominations
des souverainetés
des autorités
tout a été créé
par lui
et pour lui
vous êtes avec moi
pour sa gloire
pour qu'il prenne plaisir
dans sa création
donc
pour plus
qui est dans nos dialogues
pour convaincre
les personnes
qui vivent
selon l'ordre des dieux
elle est mieux
pour elle
nous devons
avant tout
au lieu
de faire
nos évangélisations
focalisées
sur la joie
de celui qui écoute
on doit être plus préoccupé
à faire la joie
des dieux lui-même
c'est pour la gloire
des dieux
pour la gloire
pour lui
c'est les ailes
qu'on a
qui est son ordre
dans la création
continue
de lui plaire
de refléter sa gloire
roman 11 36
car c'est de lui
par lui
et pour lui
qui sont toutes les choses
à lui
soit la gloire
dans tous les siècles
Amen
et de quelle manière
pourquoi c'est important
à nouveau
pourquoi c'est
si important
que la manière
dont la Bible
décrit
que Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
soit exactement
la manière
qu'on doit
proclamer
accepter
et croire
car c'est la manière
qui rend
le plus
la gloire
à Dieu
car à chaque fois
que la Bible
va nous dire
que Dieu
a fait toutes les choses
pour sa gloire
à nouveau
à chaque fois
qu'en Genèse chapitre 1
il nous dit
par exemple
selon son espèce
dans la durée d'un jour
avec soir
et matin
qu'il ait fait
tout cela
dans ces mêmes jours
ça maximise
le potentiel
de constater
que tout était bon
dans le sens
où
les choses
n'avaient pas besoin
de développer
les choses
n'avaient pas besoin
d'améliorer
tout était parfaitement bon
il est un créateur
capable de le faire
et par là
on maximise
la gloire de Dieu
on va séjoindre
à Dieu
en contemplant
la création
telle qu'elle est
telle qu'il l'a fait
pour dire
et cela
était bon
voilà pourquoi
l'ordre des choses
telles qu'il est créé
par Dieu
raconte
la gloire de Dieu
les cieux
racontent
la gloire de Dieu
l'étendue manifeste
l'oeuvre des séments
psaume 19 ans
roman en vent
en effet
les perfections
invisibles
les dieux
sa puissance éternelle
et sa divinité
se voient comme à l'oeil
depuis la création
du monde
quand on les considère
dans ses ouvrages
ils sont donc
inexcusables
les perfections
invisibles
cet antéologien
dit non seulement
que l'évidence scientifique
c'est
d'avoir
un être intelligent
derrière
mais un être intelligent
qui s'est laissé
découvrable
l'objectif
des dieux
c'est
il a donné
la capacité
de faire
de la science
et il a donné
à l'univers
la possibilité
d'être découvert
car le but
des dieux
c'est qu'en nous
lançant
vers l'observation
de la création
arriver à la conclusion
de la puissance
et de la sagesse
des dieux
qu'est-ce qui maximise
le plus
la louange
de la puissance
et de la sagesse
des dieux
ensuite
Genèse
pardon
Romain
voilà
Genèse 1.31
Dieu vit
tout ce qu'il avait fait
et voici
cela a été très bon
ainsi
il y a eu
un soir
et un matin
ce fut
le sixième jour
ok
donc on a traité
ces deux questions
qui sont très importantes
avec quel but
qui
l'auteur
et nous
nous allons attendre
pour entrer dans les comment
la semaine prochaine
car dans les cadres
du comment
il y a une question
dont on aura besoin
de traiter
avec plus de profondeur
et c'est notamment
la question
de la durée
nous allons considérer
les comment
par rapport à la structure
la cohérence
de toutes les choses
la structure
avec laquelle
par exemple
Dieu a créé
dans les trois premiers jours
les superstructures
dans les trois derniers jours
comment il allait peupler
ces choses
les parallèles
entre elles
qui sont très intéressants
lumière
premier jour
quatrième jour
soleil
lune
etc
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer aussi
l'emphase confessionnelle
l'emphase
qui représente
les dogmes
ou la doctrine
historique
l'abordage
des écritures
qui est
les faits
que Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
en six jours
littéraux
nous savons
qu'il y a
des possibilités
d'interprétation
qui nous ont été proposées
plus récemment
dans l'histoire
ses possibilités
principales
sont quatre
l'interprétation
du jour
comme en
longue période
l'interprétation
allégorique
ou symbolique
du jour
l'interprétation
qu'on appelle
les cadres
fonctionnels
ou les frameworks
les cadres
fonctionnels
et là
ce sont ceux
qui veulent
suggérer tout simplement
qu'il y a
des principes
théologiques
qui doivent être
trouvés
mais Genèse 1
ne serait pas
un récit
littéral
mais plutôt
fonctionnel
pour nous donner
plutôt des pistes
de comment
l'univers
a été organisé
mais pas forcément
dans cette durée
ou dans cette littéralité
mon objectif
c'est de vous montrer
que ces trois
possibilités
ne sont pas
plausibles
vis-à-vis
surtout
à l'enseignement
interne
des écritures
ok
et
la proposition
historique
confessionnelle
c'est comme la confession
des fois nous propose
de créer
ou de faire
en six jours
les mondes
et tous ces
qu'ils se trouvent
et donc
nous allons
nous arrêter ici
je voulais finir
avec une citation
qui peut vous donner
déjà des indices
par rapport
à la relation
entre
Exode
et
Genèse
à 5
donc l'une
de ces théories
va proposer
qu'il a eu
un gap
un vide
un fossé
entre
les versets 1
et les versets 2
mais ce qui est intéressant
à remarquer
c'est
comment
en Exode
Dieu va reprendre
Dieu lui-même
va traiter
Genèse 1
comme littéral
et historique
et la phrase
qu'il va déclarer
elle est très similaire
donc
Genèse 1
nous dit
au commencement
Dieu créa
les cieux
et la terre
la terre était en forme
vide
et il y avait
des ténèbres
à la surface
de l'abîme
et l'esprit
de Dieu
s'est mauvais
au-dessous des eaux
Dieu dit
que la lumière
foire
la lumière
fut
ok
Dieu vit
que la lumière
était bonne
et Dieu sépara
la lumière
d'avec les ténèbres
Dieu appela
la lumière
jour
et il appela
les ténèbres
nuit
ainsi
il eut un soir
et un matin
ce fut
les premiers jours
donc notre position
la position majoritaire
la position
que j'aimerais
que vous voyez
quelque part
la grande difficulté
au moins
de voir différemment
c'est que
tous ces récits
du verset 1 à 5
suggèrent
un même jour
et pourquoi
car au verset 11
d'Exode
chapitre 20
nous lisons
à partir du verset 8
mais surtout
le verset 11
donc
souviens-toi
du jour du repos
pour les sanctifier
tu travailleras six jours
et tu feras tout ton ouvrage
mais les septième jours
est le jour du repos
de l'éternel
ton Dieu
donc traitant
de manière littérale
le septième jour
tu ne feras aucun ouvrage
ni toi
ni ton fils
ni ta fille
ni ton serviteur
ni ta servante
ni ton bétail
ni l'étranger
qui est dans tes portes
verset 11
attention
car
en six jours
l'éternel
a fait
les cieux
la terre
et la mer
et tout ce qui a contenu
en six jours
vous voyez
l'impossibilité
de revenir
en Genèse
chapitre 1
verset 1
la même expression
presque
au commencement
Dieu créa
les cieux
et la terre
et ici verset 11
car en six jours
l'éternel
a fait les cieux
la terre
et la mer
et tout ce
qui est contenu
et il s'est reposé
les septième jour
c'est pourquoi
l'éternel
a béni les jours
du repos
et l'a sanctifié
vous voyez les parallèles
donc c'est dans cette direction
qu'on va
je vais vous présenter
beaucoup d'autres évidences
pour discuter
la durée des jours
au dédent
d'écriture
et après
on va traiter
dans une autre leçon
les questions
des évidences scientifiques
par rapport à la datation
de la terre
mais plus important
et plus intéressant
c'est de voir comment
c'est une impossibilité
entre biblique
de croire différemment
ok
ce sont ces comparaisons
avec les textes bibliques
eux-mêmes
et puis on va
c'est de voir comment
on va